what we see is not what's out there
[Music]
we do not know why we are here
we do not know who built the silent
and why we are underground
we only know
the world outside our Sanctuary is death
boil The Pact
rule
it's do not say you want to go outside
or you will go outside
don't you ever think about the world
Beyond The Silo what if what we see
out there
Dino mechanical there's always someone
who has a theory about the sign up I
need to find out the truth
I found something that might hold the
answers to a lot of questions
be quiet
[Music]
and keep your head down
[Applause]
are you willing to give everything you
have for this
[Music]
clock is running there isn't much time
left
this is a threat to order in the silence
I don't care about order what about
the truth
some Mysteries
they're best left unsolved
[Music]